you mentioned Billy Madison I just want
to ask you this story because the
dodgeball scene in that movie is so
great yeah whipping the dodgeballs yeah
kids and then I found out later on and I
don't know if it's true that that didn't
go quite as you thought it would go it
wasn't set up correct it was I it was
our first movie that we were doing and
we had some control of and we wrote that
movie Billy Madison is the dodgeball
scene I'm hitting all these first
graders really hard really hard
dodgeball and so we go to shoot it and
this is like 20 years ago guys so I'm
just guessing this is correct but I so I
hit some kid pretty hard and he gets
upset and he starts crying and then a
parents all come up to me what's the
deal and I say what do you mean what
happened
they're like the kid you nailed that kid
as I go no no no that's the scene I'm
supposed to have like a big guy went
back to school I'm supposed to plug all
these kids it's part of the joke and
they were like I know no no what are you
talking about they're like go I said
then they read the script ago they this
six they don't read you I said but I
know yeah come on and anyways I said all
right I won't do it or something and I
think I told the guys to roll anyways
and I nailed a bunch of kids something
awful like that but those kids grew up
and guess who they are today I don't
know
[Applause]
you